a gentleman named jose posuello on
twitter mentioned something i had said
once about running a bed and breakfast
being just as much work as running a
hotel chain i don't remember saying this
but i have told this to many founders i
must have said it here on the podcast
and here's what he says our restaurant
journey has been so complete it's
incredible the breadth and depth of
problems to tackle jason said somewhere
that running a bed and breakfast is as
much work as a hotel chain might be
slaughtering the quote seems it's true
next stop scaling and let's pause here
and i'll tell you what i've been talking
and i mentioned this in my my first book
angel and many and one of the things
that i did say in the previous book
angel and that i still subscribe to is
when you're thinking about your time and
it this will be relevant for the next
book which i won't talk about what it's
about yet because i'm in the process of
talking to my previous publisher and my
agent i haven't even picked a publisher
yet
so i'm going to have an auction or
something for the book and i'll probably
go with my existing publishers they're
pretty great harper
business
as long as they pay a decent price for
it not that i'm doing it for the money
i'll be totally honest i'm writing the
books now because i love the act of
writing and i love when you read a book
that i've written
when you say it had an impact on me and
so this tweet is what i live for because
he obviously read this in the book uh he
might have heard on the podcast as well
but the point is pick a business that
scales
warby parker is a business that scales
but there are businesses that scale more
if you're an entrepreneur whatever
business you pick if you're running a
hot dog stand a bed and breakfast a
hotel chain or airbnb
uh or aws whatever it is you're running
if you're a great entrepreneur you're
gonna spend 80 hours a week running it
and you're going to spend another
every other waking hour thinking about
it it's just the nature of
entrepreneurship is that it is all
encompassing if you're not all in if
you're not thinking about your business
constantly you probably pick the wrong
business but you want to pick a business
that scales and that's high margin and
many of the founders i meet especially
young ones who are starting their
journey or older ones who are scared or
don't have you know the ability to think
big because they're just conservative
this conservative nature leads you to
pick a business
that doesn't scale
such as a service business or making a
physical product and those businesses
you're going to work just as hard but
you're not going to get the reward so
always level yourself up if you were
thinking about starting a bed and
breakfast think about starting a
marketplace of bed and breakfast right
if you were thinking about serving if
you were thinking about creating a web
hosting company think about making a
platform like aws always try to think
one level higher if you were thinking
about creating a delivery food service
think about creating cloud kitchens like
diego and travis did they
just thought one level of more
abstraction up and then you could have
more profit and build a bigger business
and so jose thank you for writing a note
it really you filled my bucket as the
kids say in preschool you want to fill
the other person's bucket and not drain
it and so you made me feel great thanks
i appreciate it in today's startup
landscape committing to security and
compliance is vital for growth and proof
of your company's security posture has
never been more important as you scale
you might start to receive more sock two
requests from customers and that's where
drata comes in drata is an advanced
automation platform used by some of the
world's leading chief information
security officers or csos strata will
help you successfully meet requirements
support enterprise deal flow and
continually track compliance strata also
helps customers easily prepare for and
clear sock 2 and other audits so you can
go from zero to audit ready in a matter
of weeks need more take it from philip
martin chief security officer at
coinbase and here's his quote it became
clear to me right away that drata is an
engineering powerhouse the solution
they've developed is well ahead of other
market players their approach to deep
native integrations provides users with
the most advanced automation available
so check out drata's five-star reviews
on g2 and see why companies like clear
close smart recruiter and the good face
project work withdrata for their
compliance needs twist listeners can get
15 off and waived implementation fees at
drata.com twist d-r-a-t-a dot com slash
twist